Image scaling
Here, I have a high resolution image. The
image is nearly 2,000 pixels wide and around
1600 pixels tall. Let's say I wanted to produce
a smaller version of this image, perhaps a
thumbnail image. We want to reduce its size.
So perhaps, the simplest way to go about doing
this is to just select every nth pixel in
each row and in each column and I could do
that very simply with this MATLAB command
here.
I'm going to take every 7th pixel in the horizontal
direction and every 7th pixel in the vertical
direction and the result is a much smaller
image. This image is only 260 something pixels
wide and 220 something pixels tall. This is
a process that's known as Image Decimation,
very very simple to compute but you'll notice
that there are some artefacts in this image.
The tiled roof that we see very clearly in
the left hand image has resulted in a very
strange pattern in the right hand image. We
can see that that regular texture of the tiled
roof has disappeared and been replaced by
some rather obvious lines which don't actually
exist in the input image.
So, this is an artefact that's being introduced
into the output image by the process of decimation
and the root cause of this is a phenomenon
known as aliasing.
The simplest way to think about aliasing is
in terms of a 1-dimensional image intensity
profile. So, let's imagine that we've drawn
a line across an image and this is the intensity
profile and it varies between plus and minus
1 in this particular case and the horizontal
axis is scaled in terms of units of pixels.
So, we can see some quite high frequency variation
of the image intensity as we move across the
profile. Now, let's imagine that I sample
this profile at every 2nd pixel. So, as a
sample at pixel 0, a sample of pixel 2, at
pixel 4 and so on. Now, given that I have
made the sample shown here by the black dots,
I could also consider that the blue curve
that's shown here is equally good explanation
of the values that I've measured at these
6 sample points. This is all based on a really
important theorem from signal processing called
the Nyquist sampling theorem.
In this particular case, our sampling interval
is 2 pixels. We've chosen our samples to be
every 2nd pixel and that means that any signal
that's got a period less than twice that.
So, any single with a period that's less than
four pixels will be aliased. It will be confused
with a low frequency signal after we have
sampled.
The way to eliminate this alias in problem
is to remove the high frequency components
from the image and we've talked before about
how we can use a Gaussian curve to blur an
image and perhaps, it's been unintuitive why
we would ever want to blur an image. We go
to so much trouble to make our images sharp
and crisp and nice to look at, but convolving
with the Gaussian kernel we'll remove these
problematic high frequency components.
So in order to properly sub-sample an image,
what we need to do is to apply a Gaussian
kernels and then, sub-sample or decimate.
These 2 steps are done together in the toolbox
function iscale.
So, the iscale function, we parse in our high
resolution input image and we parse in the
scale factor. In this case, I want the image
to be 1/7th the size of the input image.
The result will be the low resolution image
shown here on the right. Notice now that those
artifacts due to aliasing have been eliminated.